sie könnte ich sein
oder sie
[Musik]
oder sie aber nie
das bin ich
mein bruder hat mich erschossen im
februar 2005 kein film den man sich
unbedingt gerne anschauen möchte
vielleicht aber die man sich unbedingt
anschauen sollte also ein wichtiger film
auch ein gut gemachter film vielleicht
weil ich damals schon egal vielleicht
ähnlich nah und alles schon so lange her
kann die nicht einfach tot bleiben
erzählt wird die geschichte einer jungen
frau die in berlin im jahr 2005
erschossen wurde von einem ihrer brüder
und zwar mit drei kopfschüssen
und dieser fall hat damals für große
aufregung gesorgt hat es war einer der
ersten fälle von sogenannten ehrenmord
der stark diskutiert wurde und was
dieser film sehr gut heraus arbeitet ist
dass es eigentlich keinen ehrenmord gibt
dieser begriff ist schon komplett
pervers das ist ein mord fertig punkt
und es gibt keine entschuldigung für die
täter es gibt keine gnade für die täter
in diesem film und das macht ihn zu
einem sehr klaren und auch sehr
ermutigend film egal was du willst du
gehörst ich will zur familie ist war es
dass du zu entscheiden die
hauptdarstellerin amila back check ist
auch diejenige die beträgt als
erzählstimme und zwar als erzählstimme
aus dem jenseits sie fängt an in dem sie
sagt dass sie die tote ist auf dem bild
und dann wird in rückblenden erzählt wie
es zu diesem punkt kam zustande werden
heißt aus der reihe zu tanzen
in einer welt in der nur
familie und ihre ehre zählen so schwer
werden heißt mit den traditionen zu
brechen
der film beginnt 1998 damals ist die
spätere das spätere opfer und 16 jahre
alt und wird zwangsverheiratet in die
türkei und damit beginnt das gesamte
drama denn ab da ist sie wirklich
gefangene ihrer familie und kommt aus
dieser situation nicht mehr aus sie
flieht vor ihrem ehemann kommt zurück
nach berlin ist schwanger wird
widerwillig von ihrer familie
aufgenommen befreit sich dann mit dem
kind zieht aus beginnt eine lehre lebt
in einer eigenen wohnung liegt das
kopftuch ab und das führt zu immer
weiteren spannungen uns zu immer
weiteren hass vor allen dingen bei den
brüdern aber auch bei der mutter auch
für den vater und der film erzählt dass
die ganze familie darin involviert ist
diese frau nicht loslassen zu wollen ja
keine freiheit zugestehen zu wollen
und verabschiedet sich eigentlich da
auch von dieser theorie des einzeltäters
die hauptdarstellerin ist wirklich sehr
gut
ich find sie spielt sehr zurückgenommen
aber auch sehr authentisch man kennt sie
jetzt ja aus verschiedenen rollen
sie spielten tatort sie spielt hat
infoblox gespielt auch in den nsu film
hat sie mitgespielt in dieser nsu
trilogie und ist jemand der sehr präsent
ist sehr präsent wirkt und sehr
authentisch und das tut diesem film
enorm gut
warum machst du das machen wir lassen's
wachsen
warum glaubst du warum ignorieren können
wir uns bitte endlich kurs fortsetzen
und in ruhe reden
nein ich will dass du zurückkommst
fertig ich kann nicht mehr zurück
warum nicht geht nicht
die produzentin ist ja sandra
maischberger und sie sorgt glaube ich
auch dafür dass dieser film eine breite
öffentlichkeit bekommen wird er soll
auch in schulen gezeigt werden ich
glaube das ist auch sehr wichtig dass
bei jungen leuten eine diskussion
stattfindet denn die personen die wir
sehen sind jugendliche
das sind jugendliche das sind ganz junge
leute das sind junge leute die hier
aufgewachsen sind aber deren familien
und deren kulturen nicht hier verwurzelt
sind und damit er eine ungeheure
spannung hineingeraten sind und was es
bedeutet freiheit zuzulassen
und was es bedeutet wenn gewalt
legitimiert wird durch ideologien oder
durch religiöse vorstellungen
das erklärt dieser fällen das macht er
sehr anschaulich und deshalb ist es
glaube ich ein film der für junge leute
sehr geeignet ist aber natürlich auch
für alle anderen ideen wird im prozess
sagen nuri hat mir verraten dass tag
ihnen die pistole gegeben hat den
richtern fehlen dafür die beweise
aber ich glaube die ich glaube dir dass
du nicht begriffen hast wie ernst alles
war weil du blind warst